[Music]
all right one very glad to see such a
good turnout for for this welcome to
session I want to say 17 because this is
the fifth year of this philosophers in
the midst of history sequence and so
each year we do in the spring we do a
still part of winter right now but
spring we'll call it we do an ancient
philosopher and then in the summertime
we do a medieval philosopher or thinker
and then we do an early modern so like
you know 16th 17th 18th century thinker
and then at the end of the year we do a
19th or 20th century thinker and each of
these is you know an interactive lecture
where what I'm focusing on is that
particular philosopher and how how
they're located in history so what is
the background what was going on how did
that influence their works how did that
affect what they did how today and
sometimes get killed because of it like
in the case of we theists awhile back
and then I talked about I talked about
some of their ideas as well but then I
also talked about why they influenced
history because it's a two-way street so
Epicurus and the Epicureans they were a
really major school in antiquity and
they're still around today interestingly
enough there's been a revival as of late
and a new literature that's developed
which is quite cool so we'll talk about
that and at any time if you've got
questions or you know there's something
that you want clarification about go
ahead and stop me and we'll continue and
talking about that I gave you two things
one is a timeline that has what was
going on with Epicurus and his life
there's not a lot we actually know about
it unfortunately and then other things
that were happening in Greece and
particularly in Athens where Epicurus
spent a lot of his life and found
has his school the garden and then I
also gave you a handout that ideally it
would be stapled but it's not three
pages and that's something that I use
for my my classes when I'm teaching
about Epicurus and Epicureanism it gives
you some of the basics of what epicurean
hedonism was all about and I suppose I
should begin right at the start by
talking about something where there's
often a misunderstanding because of the
way language has changed right so when I
say epicurean what's the alike the first
thing that comes to mind okay food so
that's one pleasure right and what kind
of food is epicurean good good food okay
what else what else you just associate
with it can a high-class foodie food
right yeah may be rich tasty okay so
there's that and then what else do you
associate with the term epicurean you
got the food you're at the table
Epicurious right yeah you know usually
we think about wine or other intoxicants
so and epicurean would be you know
having fine wine with with their food
and courses that they appreciate
probably not eating too much they
wouldn't be you know stuffing their face
they would go for quality rather than
quantity and you know there's there's
some of that in ancient epicureanism but
epicures himself was probably a
vegetarian
he didn't indulge an awful lot you know
he said that drinking wine not that good
of an idea because you know you could
hangovers and leads her to do dumb
things and you know so this gives you
kind of an idea about what his idea of a
good time was like somebody said can I
do anything for you he said yeah give me
a little pot of cheese that it did be
nice and then he would just snack on
so it's it's not quite so hedonistic
aliy sensual the the kind of philosophy
that he was teaching what we'll talk
about that in a moment there were other
people there are plenty of people in
ancient times who are really into food
and drink you know some of you may have
looked at cookbooks from ancient Greek
or even even more so the Romans and some
of the crazy dishes they used to make or
you read some of the literature and
about these feasts that they would have
it was they really did know how to get
the most out of food as a matter of fact
there's some things that they ate to the
point of extinction at one point or
another what you know that can happen
with us as well but you know that's a
lot to do in ancient times
so the Epicureans weren't into that they
were into a life of pleasure having as
much pleasure as possible and as little
pain so we'll talk about you know what
what that looks like in just a bit
but let's start right by talking about
this guy Epicurus and some of the
background he is born outside of Athens
he's born on a place called Salmons
to nail Cleese and Cara strata both of
whom were Athenian born and his father
nail cleaves was an Athenian citizen so
that means that Epicurus is also an
Athenian citizen which is important
because if you go to Athens like
Aristotle did later on Aristotle was not
an Athenian citizen not being a citizen
means you can't actually own land
there's all sorts of other things that
you're precluded from because of that
Epicurus is is essentially a person
living in a colony of Athens in a
different place and so he's going to go
back to Athens after a while and Athens
is where philosophy wasn't quite born
but where it really took off so you look
at some of the things that are happening
in the you know sixty or so years
leading up to Epicurus being born in 341
Socrates dies you know I think all of
you know about his trial you know
there's different reports of it it looks
like he may have kind of thrown it a bit
if you go by the apology that Plato
writes but he's probably gonna get
convicted anyway and that's and that's
just right after 400 BC of course
they're not you know counting BC or
anything like that but it's 399 and then
some schools start getting founded Plato
founds his school in 387 Isocrates fight
founds a school of rhetoric in Athens in
392 somebody you know in the the three
80s and three three 70s and three 60s
you know Aristotle being born
Democritus the great Greek philosopher
that Epicurus is going to draw upon
dying and then and hissing is the cynic
and his the knees would have been a
contemporary of Plato a student of
Socrates just like Plato was as was
another person eros tipis I probably
should have put him on on here as well
because eros tipis was one of the first
hedonist philosophers the first person
to actually say the whole goal of life
is to have a good time and here's how
you do it and he had a different way of
understanding it than Epicurus would so
you've got all these these people you
know sorts shuffling off the scene
having made their contribution by the
time that that Epicurus is born about
six years before that Plato dies and his
nephew takes over the Academy in Athens
so by the time that Epicurus is around
and especially by the time he's a young
adult there's this tradition of having
schools of philosophy and they're
centered in Athens you can go to other
places but that's the main that's the
main location
and you know another key thing that's
happening at that time that affects the
epicurean philosophy is the Greek city
states are ceasing to be the main
political game in town you can say
you're all you know familiar with the
Peloponnesian War right where who are
the two main antagonists and that that
story two big cities you know world civ
this is the thing that they make you
memorize Athens and Sparta right and
they represent two different ways of
life you know the Spartans are
authoritarian but they're also you know
able to like be unified militarily the
Athenians democracy but they have a very
hard time like you know getting things
done and then what they leave out of the
story when they say that is that pretty
much everybody else in Greece is stuck
winding up on one side or another and
spills over in all sorts of other areas
spills over into Asia Minor spills over
into Sicily and it you know it goes on
for quite a while eventually you know
Athens grows to become so big they call
it the tyrant city and you know when
when the Spartans look like liberators
which is what they were called at at one
point you know the Athenians have really
screwed up and they they have you know
as the old story with Greek ready hubris
and then you have the fall alright and
that happens to Athens they get City
gets sacked and all of that and what
they're doing is they're spending an
awful lot of time and energy on these
struggles with each other struggles that
are reflected in their politics and
their economies and all that and
meanwhile there's this well there's a
couple powers growing up North before
Macedon becomes the big game in town
there's another city that became very
important and they managed to beat the
Spartans in battle like on the field of
battle that was the themes and so you
start getting all these alliances and
all of these leagues they
these city-states where some of the
city-states
like Athens are smarter Thebes they can
kind of run the show and then the rest
are kind of stuck along for the ride
they get to be allies sometimes being an
ally is more like being like a henchman
almost for a sidekick you don't really
have a lot of agency and you know all of
that stuff eventually sorts itself out
and the Persians are over to the east
this entire time sort of laughing at
these stupid Greeks and what they're
doing but they'll also hire the Greeks
as mercenaries for their own dynastic
struggles as well
so eventually another Kingdom which you
know the Greeks down in the south
consider really only about half Greek
but it was authentically you know
Hellenic Macedon starts to take over and
so by the time that Epicurus is you know
in his childhood Philip of Macedon takes
over most of Greece he defeats Athens
and Thebes to the big cities there he
forms the League of Corinth and then
he's assassinated in 336 BC and at the
time that he's assassinated he was
preparing for a big thing he was going
to get ready to invade Persia and so his
young son Alexander who we all know is
Alexander the Great yeah and so in the
Middle East he's known as Alexander the
Terrible - a lot of people still but
he's known as Alexander the Great in the
West he takes that war machine that has
been put together any he he's also very
charismatic very dynamic he invades the
Persian Empire and for about the next
twenty years he's chasing the various
Persian forces all up and down the
Middle East and North Africa he takes
over Egypt fairly quickly he does defeat
you know the Persian Emperor but that
isn't the end of the story because
there's still you know local governors
they are called who have their own
forces and he has to fight them he goes
all the way to India and you know I
think many of you know the story about
what happens there his troops have been
marching now for 20 years are kind of
sick of it you think about our military
commitments people have been you know
talking about how in Afghanistan which
is where Alexander was we've now reached
the point where young soldiers who
deployed at that time could actually
have kids who are now deploying because
we've been there for so long well
Alexander just had these guys around for
that that entire time some of them would
be more recent they'd have come from
Greece at other times but you know
that's a long time to follow somebody
these campaigns by the time that he by
the time that that happens
Epicurus is in Athens he he'd studied
under this this plate inist Pam Phyllis
for four years as a young man and then
by the time that he's 18 they said
walked a happens we're not actually
quite sure what he was doing there may
have been military service and they have
just been going there as a citizen and
Alexander then dies that that year and
the Macedonian Empire they start to
figure well what are we going to do with
this gigantic entity that's that's now
under Macedonian rule and and there's
you know he left a son and he had a wife
but the Sun is extremely young and so
you have a regent and then you have
these different you could call them
governors or generals whatever you want
to call them nowadays we typically call
them the deed Okoye the successors and
they're eventually going to start
splitting the empire off between them
for Greece it's more or less going to be
Macedon ruling what's what's you know in
south of it in Greece and then you know
Persia itself will be taken over by so
Lucas and his dynasty Egypt by Ptolemy
and his dynasty and then there's a few
other things here and there and they
fight over it but what it means is from
you know the I was saying the Greek
city-state eventually became not not
that important on a grand political
scale like setting your own policies
after you know 20 years of this there
there isn't any independence you know
you're under whoever happens to have
taken you over and so you know the the
things that previous generations had had
going where they could say well what is
our city gonna do it's more like what we
live with today right we're in this
state of Wisconsin and we can set our
own policies for some things but we're
part of a much larger unity and it's not
like we can say well we don't like that
the federal government is doing we're
going to secede and go our own way and
figure it all out
Wisconsin actually did threaten to do
that at one time shortly before the
Civil there's total trivia before the
Civil War a lot of people don't know
that our governor Randall Alexander I
think it was his name 6th Governor of
Wisconsin if Lincoln didn't win he
threatened to have Wisconsin secede from
the union so it wasn't just southern
state saying that they are going to
secede it was northern states too if
things went the other way didn't happen
you know and they probably would have
been quite a big battle if they had but
you know it's not really that much of an
option for us right and it wasn't much
of an option for ancient Greek
city-states either
Athens did in fact revolt and that
revolt was crushed almost immediately in
a very short war and so you know
Epicurus is is now coming up with in a
you could say a matrix in which people
are still very interested in doing
things but politics isn't isn't so
important anymore or at least grand you
know we could call it grand strategy
politics politics of what your whole
city is going to do it's more like if
you go into politics
be somebody who's gonna help manage
things you know let's make sure that the
games get played right and you know once
they actually have things like aqueducts
sounds the ancient Greece and that
Romans gonna have to come in before that
but you know the kind of making sure
those projects go along correctly taxes
get paid right so
Epicurus you know he does have a few
things to say about politics but not an
awful lot and the Epicureans themselves
have been largely disengaged from that
so epicures while all this is going on
and well you know sort of schools are
developing and changing hands he travels
to a few places he studies with this
this philosopher for a short time now so
funnies learns about Democritus from him
sort of out you know out runs his
usefulness very quickly and breaks from
him and then Epicurus rejoins his family
this the people from Samos have been
relocated to colophon again you know
dynastic issues in the Macedonian Empire
and so he's there and then he goes to a
place called Mytilene which is on the
island of Lesbos he's teaching there for
a fairly short time again we don't know
the full story but apparently what he
was teaching did not go over well and he
had to get out of town and so he
relocates to lamp lamp circus and there
he meets a lot of the people that are
going to eventually go with him the
athens and help him in starting a school
so in 306 a very important time he
returns to Athens and he uses some money
to purchase a garden and you know
Gardens sort of think of like an estate
right at this big area that's kind of
walled off and he establishes he's been
teaching already he's been teaching the
epicurean philosophy he's got followers
now he's got a place for his followers
to go
and practice this this life together so
he teaches philosophy there not too long
after that you see some of these these
other you know philosophers dying off
and schools again changing hands Kron
tastes the cynic would be somebody who's
kind of important as a marking a certain
time because he was going to he was the
teacher of one of the other really
important founders of the school Zeno
the person who founded the stoic school
the Epicureans and the Stoics became the
two most important schools of late
antiquity and they were really rivals to
each other in a way that we'll talk
about in a bit so Epicurus them you know
for the next essentially thirty six
years he's teaching in his place he
doesn't go anywhere he doesn't travel he
just you know hangs out and lives a good
life and doesn't awful lot of writing
and I'll tell you about in a minute and
then in 270 he dies of a stone blockage
of his urinary tract and he names his
friend here Marcus as the successor is
the skull are a school arc is the person
who runs the school so each of the
ancient schools and there were there
were a number of them would have
somebody who's like the the guy the the
person in charge he's the the school arc
of the Epicurean school or the he didn't
they didn't call it the Epicurean school
at the time they just called it the
garden but he's in charge so he gets to
name his successor he would have named a
different guy but that guy had died
younger than him his very close friend
metrodorus yeah he died in 278 so about
eight years before at the Kuras
otherwise you know he would have been
the successor now I mentioned that that
he wrote a lot
Epicurus was one of the
most prolific authors of antiquity and
we have almost none of what he wrote so
there's the I'll tell you first give you
an idea I'm not gonna like read off the
entire list of what do you wrote it's in
de a genies laertes lives of the
philosophers book ten if you're really
interested in it he wrote a book called
on nature in 37 books a book was a
scroll so just to give you an idea about
how long of a text that would be if you
have some of you've read Plato's
Republic right that's ten books or
Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics ten bucks
thirty seven books would be almost four
times that so that must have been one
hell of a text to read thirty it would
be for thirty seven Scrolls that you
would put into a bag that you would
carry around with you
he also wrote I was reading a few of the
titles of his books on atoms of the void
a very important point of of epicurean
natural philosophy on love wouldn't it
be interesting to have that book against
the megarians okay the megarians were
another school this is a very common
thing in ancient times too right against
so-and-so you know why they're all wrong
on choice and avoidance on the gods we
have that we know more about the
epicurean theology the banquet or the
symposium when we hear the word
symposium again this is one of those
words has changed its meaning over time
so two of socrates students wrote
symposia Plato wrote one that's one of
the greatest works of Western literature
in which it's all about love and they
give these speeches and you might have
read it or you might not have if you
haven't you should take a look at it
it's really quite good zen ofin wrote
another book called the symposium about
a different drinking party which is what
a symposium is where Socrates has other
conversations with people and actually
almost gets in a fight with one of the
entertainer's Epicurus wrote a symposium
and we we know that it's not just
Diogenes Lear
is telling us about this plutarch later
on mentions it and tells us a bit about
what's in it tantalizingly you know
little but it must have been quite a
work essay on just dealing you know
opinions on the passions sen music that
would be interesting to check out as
well he wrote about 43 works all told
not including some of the letters that
he wrote as well now we have
unfortunately only five undisputed
documents by by epicurus we have three
letters there's another letter that's
very short that maybe by him and then
there's two sort of like best hits lists
they have different names sometimes it's
called sovereign Maxim's or you know
here one translation fundamental
propositions the Greek is Korea I'd dark
side which means beliefs or ideas or
judgments and the ones that are the most
important the kudrya is the Lord
you know the ruler and that's very short
and then they discovered one that's
called the Vatican sayings because they
found in the Vatican Library the Vatican
Library there's another total side note
sometimes there's conspiracy theories
about how the church is hiding this and
hiding that and it's it's not the case
at all it's just such a mess and and so
disorganized that like with many other
old libraries they often don't know what
they have and things are mislabeled and
then you get a scholar going down in
there
and they'll open up a text and they'll
be like this isn't actually what's in
the table of contents what the hell is
this and then they read it a bit more
and if they've got the right background
they're like oh my goodness this is this
thing that that was been lost for
centuries and you know somebody just
misplaced it I actually had a professor
who did that
when he was a graduate student he went
to the Vatican Library and he got an
academic article out of this he was
paging through something and I don't
remember the exact details and he found
a couple pages that didn't fit and he
was like well I think this might be this
and he did a little bit of research and
he wrote an article and provided a
translation of this text that you know
they put in the wrong place so there's
there's something called the Vatican
sayings which is a better you know good
good portion of it is actually just the
same sayings as the Nair the principal
doctrines but there's a few other cool
things and they're about friendship and
justice and all of that now it gets even
more interesting the reason why we have
any of Epicurus is stuff is because day
ahajni is laertes really thought he was
interesting he thought it was worth the
time to copy down a few things by
Epicurus just to give the reader an
impression of what Epicurus had to say
and he copied it out line by line into
his lives of the Philosopher's had he
not done that we wouldn't have any of
those things and nobody would have been
able to recognize the Vatican sayings as
what it was so you might say well why
did they lose all this stuff well you
know when it comes to ancient works we
don't have any of Aristotle's dialogues
he wrote dialogues that were supposedly
as good as Plato's we probably have
anywhere between 7 to 10% of the stoic
literature that was written there's just
a lot of stuff that's lost we have
nothing by the foot by the cynics
nothing by the megarians the only things
we have are little fragments it's just
you know ancient literature it's rather
unfortunate we could discover some some
lost tax and there is a possibility of
some of the texts at Herculaneum that
have been discovered as we're like you
know going through them I'll talk about
that in just a little bit maybe we'll
find some new stuff by Epicurus in there
so that that could be kind of it's kind
of cool that doesn't happen very often
so in any case what did the epic
darienne's actually think and and
teaching what was their way of life I
mentioned that it's it's all about
pleasure and avoiding pain so if you
think about the things that we find
pleasant what are the things that most
people you would say find what the
Epicureans an ancient philosophers
called choice worthy worthy of being
pursued because they they're pleasant
what do we get pleasure from you
mentioned food and wine wine we can
think of as in terms of the taste but
also the intoxicated so people also
enjoy getting high in other ways
you know marijuana hard drugs like math
and cocaine and stuff like that so those
are you know people like those because
they're pleasurable right are a little
kick of caffeine in the morning that's
that's pleasurable people smoke because
smoking is you know despite with the ads
say it is it is fun and you know it
doesn't taste that great all the time
but once you get used to it you kind of
get hooked so there's all of those
things what are other things that people
see as pleasurable
yeah so sexual pleasure right and then
there's also you know something that can
come out of that you mentioned intimacy
friendship affection of others our
reputations you know it's nice to have
people like you it doesn't feel good
when people are like you're terrible you
know and we do that with social media
you know post something now most things
only allow you to put a like they don't
allow you to say this is terrible
some some websites let you down vote
things but most most don't but you know
some people are very motivated by
getting those those virtual thumbs-up or
claps or whatever it happens to be what
else what else do people
joy music yeah so all sorts of things
appeal to that some of some of which may
be dramatic in nature you know like
that's part of why we like to watch
these TV shows I mean some people like
it as just background noise
there might be a certain pleasure to
that but a lot of us watch shows because
we you know we get caught up in the
story and then you know we go to art
museums and actually look at the
paintings or sculpture we go to concerts
listen to the music so there's a whole
variety of things that we find pleasant
laying in bed on a cold day under the
warm blankets that's a sensual pleasure
right
and so the Epicureans they thought that
if we want to manage our lives well and
have the most pleasure as possible and
the least pain because if pleasures the
good pain is the evil or the bad and
pain can cover a lot of stuff then we
have to we have to understand the nature
of pleasures and so they made all these
interesting distinctions one of the
distinctions is between bodily and
mental pleasures so if you think about
what goes into appreciating a meal right
for those people who are foodies so
there's you know you can you can go to a
nice fancy restaurant and get I don't
know like a hundred dollar entree or
something and just sit there and just
shovel it into your face and you know
enjoy the the feeling that's on your
time very shortly and the feeling of
fullness but that's kind of a bad
management of pleasures right because
what are you supposed to be doing you're
supposed to be savoring it and you know
the people go to those restaurants they
often want to know like well where did
this where did this chicken come from
you know and what are you doing to
prepare it oh you're using this you know
sauce and so there's some intellectual
stuff there right people who are like
beer fans there's so many bitterness
agents in this or not agents units
that becomes a what hops I think I smell
Cascade hops in this one you know with
this IPA no people can get very
technical about this sort of thing and
it's the same way with music right you
can distinguish you can tell who really
knows their classical music because you
say what do you think about Bach and
they're like well which piece right and
then by which performer oh I really like
that I don't know enough about Bach
songs make up names
I like the Smith performance of Bach's
eighteenth concerto and again I'm just
making stuff up I don't really like the
Herbert one I think he's you know too
forceful with the keyboard or so that's
all intellectual stuff right that's no
longer just merely bodily or sensual and
Epicurus noticed something about bodily
pleasures so bodily pleasures they're
very short and variation even ones like
laying in bed I mean how long can you
lay in bed before you get tired of
laying in bed and once the thing that's
giving you the bodily pleasure goes away
that's that's pretty much it for it
mental pleasures can last a long time
I mean can any of you think of like an
experience that you had that was
intensely pleasurable maybe twenty years
ago can you call it up to mind not in
perfect vividness but you can reflect on
it and then you can like enjoy it again
now listen let's do the opposite of that
think about something that happened out
of 20-30 years ago and it was totally
mortifying you were embarrassed in some
way and you're probably over it now but
you might still if you were the sort of
person to obsess about it you could
still be lingering over it or if
somebody slighted you somebody treated
you badly twenty years ago that SOB you
know they're like long gone they you
know
connection with them but they're still
there as we say in your head well that's
a mental pain and that can go on the
rest of your life if you allow it so
Epicurus noticed that and he was in
opposition to the other hedonist who
said the goal is to have as much
physical pleasure as possible
Epicurus said no mental pleasure is
really more important and avoiding
mental pains the other thing he said
another distinction is a little bit more
technical it's between what he calls we
can translate it as moving and static
pleasures or active and cata stomach
pleasures so an active pleasure is like
say drinking drinking wine right you you
like the smell if if you all enjoy wine
okay so you're smelling it
you're doing all the things you're
supposed to do swirl it around you look
at it right then you taste a little take
a little taste and there's the you know
it's a good one and after a while you
start to get buzzed all of those are
what we call active pleasures but
there's other things
Epicurus said and you might not buy this
but this is something that they were
very insistent on there's other
pleasures that result from not doing
something but taking something away so
like when you're really cold outside and
you come in and sit by the fire and warm
up that's a static pleasure that's a can
of stomach pleasure it's not an active
pleasure you're just taking away a pain
when you're like just resting when as we
say you know chilling out right or
hanging out or something like that like
he's doing in the garden and you're not
really doing much of anything but you're
just enjoying yourself he said that is
actually more pleasant than like getting
drunk or having sex or any of these
sorts of things and well maybe he's
wrong about that but there is definitely
something to making the distinction
right
sometimes he actually says people have
it wrong they think that there's
pleasure over here and pain over here
and then a state of neither in the
middle a state of rest this is what Eris
tipis thought Epicure says that
is where the real pleasure lies and so
as an epicurean your goal would be to
have these kinds of pleasures the the
middle you know intense because they're
essentially resting pleasures that can
go on for a long time
and as many of the other pleasures that
are more active as you can you can have
without screwing things up for yourself
like obviously you can't get drunk all
the time or you could have a lot of pain
and removing as many pains as possible
that's the good life everything else you
know is important insofar as it leads to
that but that is the good life and
that's what his followers thought and
taught and that's what they practiced
and they live together in this garden of
course they would go outside and do
shopping and things like that right and
they did have kids he didn't but he in
his will he mentions okay I want this
person taken care of this person wanted
one of his followers actually named his
kid Epicurus after him so so they're
obviously some of them are doing that
but they're they're all practicing this
this life together and something almost
like a sect you know and the word that
we often translate insect in in Greek in
a religious context it was used for
sects of philosophers hide races it
means to to take it was the word that we
get a heresy from later on right you
choose something you choose a deliberate
way of life what we've nowadays would
call an intentional way of living that's
what the Epicureans we're doing as
groups and they did it in Athens and
then it started getting transplanted to
all sorts of other places as well
pleasure in yeah was it focused on did
the practice for you as an individual
focus or was there also an aspect where
and I don't mean like into the kind of
thing where you would where there was a
part of it was the pleasure of the group
was the pleasure of others it's both
and that's actually a good segue into
something else so the Epicureans would
get criticized by a lot of people who
for a variety of reasons and one of them
was you know that it seems like all
they're really interested in is pleasure
in pain that's kind of a piggish kind of
life that's one criticism another
criticism is well what about morality
you know right and wrong you're only
doing the right thing because it's
pleasant for you and then the other big
criticism was well wait a second what
about friendship if you're only friends
with somebody because you get pleasure
from them you're not really friends with
them for their own sake you're just kind
of using them aren't you and and you
know if you're if you're a selfish
epicurean why would you care about your
friends pleasure and so the Epicureans
may add responses to that they say
listen Epicurious he actually says it's
in the principal doctrines friendship is
one of the best things in life it's and
he had a couple reasons well some of
which seemed kind of instrumental
friendship helps you to not be afraid
because even though I've got friends so
when I get sick or when I know there's a
famine or something like that I'll be
taken care of and people won't come
along and steal my stuff so there's that
part but then he said yeah there's that
that's true but there's also something
intrinsically valuable about friendship
and you know friendship could be what we
typically nowadays think of as a
friendship where there's no sexual or
erotic or romantic aspect to it but it
could also include that sort of thing as
well that fell into the kind of
relationship that they called friendship
both depending on who it was I mean you
could be an epicurean
and be kind of a jerk epicurean right
but then the other Epicureans that come
along and be like well you're not really
understanding the whole doctrine you
know let's let's let's have another
lecture and talk something like that it
so the curious thought that the
cessation
yeah what's pleasure yeah I mean that
was one of the greatest pleasures and he
also felt that we should try to avoid
pain as much as possible because that
also is a good how would you reconcile
the fact that you can't avoid the
pleasure from that experience oh well
you've already experienced plenty of
pains by the time that you're doing this
sort of thing you know I mean by the
time that you're a child you've already
known what it's like to be wet you know
cold hungry you know and really if
there's we don't really know much about
like how they were bringing up children
or anything like that presumably they're
they probably had something some sort of
teaching for them but by the time that
you're an adult you know life is
probably unless you've been really
really lucky life is probably giving you
enough stuff that you have a good sense
of what you're trying to avoid and it
doesn't just include physical pain it
also includes like fear or being upset
about things like being being you know
angry all the time or being sad so you
know I mean it's kind of an interesting
idea though let's say you were a really
really really successful epicurean and
you started out when you were a kid and
you managed to avoid like every pain
possible so you have almost like just a
book learning about about them and
you're 80 years old right maybe might at
that time there's such dim memories
that's sort of the sort of issue that
you're worried about what would come up
but I don't think it did for most most
Epicureans I think they thought that the
world knocks us around enough that we we
know are what well you know and and we
probably screwed things up so like you
know take let's take the drinking and
getting hungover thing right so I would
imagine that probably most kids in
ancient Greece probably did the same
similar things to what a lot
uh stood as kids and what kids still do
today which is get into mom and dad's
wine and you don't know how much to
drink or how to properly appreciate it
and get drunk and then like the next day
you know you want to die everything's
too loud evander there's probably a lot
of those sort of situations or you had a
falling in love and having the
relationship go to go to pieces you know
and so you know the goal was to try to
provide a refuge for the person from
from how you know how crappy life was if
you don't manager your pleasures and
pains properly and Epicurus you know he
comes to be called the title they use
dream is so toward which means Savior
they also use the word hero for him in
his own time not just later with
Lucretius who turns him into almost like
a a god-like Saint figure who's here to
like help us not you know screw up our
lives and lucretius is much more anti
religious than Epicurus is but
Epicurious thought that you know a lot
of people are are afraid of things they
don't have to be afraid of and that
causes them a lot of anguish and and
suffering and it could also spill over
their relations with others right if I
if I'm in a relationship with with
somebody and I'm constantly anxious it's
probably there's no fun for them right
decisions they make you make oh I can't
go to this this thing what would happen
if I go there you know that's I mean
were they well the other conclusions or
whatever you know Epicurus didn't well
for the most part there were there were
some who again we don't know that much
about these these these people but but I
would side if Athens
yeah anybody who is an epicurean would
probably have a day job
oh yeah yeah wouldn't they be one of
that one ideally you want to page that
what I like right yeah so if you can get
that if not then yeah it's sort of a
trade-off
you know I mean let's say you're a
working-class epicurean today you don't
have the the option of not working right
and so you go to your job and maybe your
boss is a jerk and the conditions aren't
great and you're like well I got to put
in my eight hours of crap you know now
so that I can enjoy my 16 hours of not
crap it kind of varied my circumstances
exactly yeah and that's exactly why
you're doing it if you're not being paid
you don't show up so that's that's an it
that's an interesting the sadist would
be more problematic than the masochist
right because if if and this is this is
one of the you know
desaad was was one of the people who
call themselves a libertine and The
Libertines they saw themselves as a
certain kind of epicurean as much later
in like the 18th century
yeah Epicurus would say in doing that
you're violating justice which is bad
and justice is not some sort of cosmic
absolute it's it's the norms of the
society and but it's also sort of you
know compartments that you ought to have
so that you can live with with other
people he had some kind of weird
arguments that I don't think a lot of
people really buy but epicurean seemed
about you know if you commit injustice
you can never really be sure you'll get
away with it so you're gonna it's not
gonna be a pleasant life for you because
you always have to be looking over your
back and I don't think that's the case
at all and I think the sadist is
perfectly fine
yeah they're they're perfectly fine with
that but you know I think a Pickers
would would end up saying something
along the lines of listen you're
creating pain for other people so that's
bad and it's it's it's pleasant in one
way for you but it's a
of inhuman pleasure you know it goes
against here they'd probably bring in
like conceptions of human nature and
again we're handicapped by the fact that
we don't have too much of their their
literature the masochist is a little bit
tougher I mean if you so if you derive
pleasure there's two really two kinds of
masochism right there's a masochism of
you get pain and because of the physical
pain you feel you derive some sort of
pleasure usually sexual pleasure from
that and then there's the aspect of like
humiliation or lack of agency or stuff
like that and they can be combined quite
often but you could be one without the
other and I guess an epicurean the men
the mental want to be more problematic
for them I guess what's got even pain
circuits miss wiry getting you know
whipped or something like that actually
makes you feel pleasure then you know
apart from any sort of societal scandal
it might create or something like that
maybe that the Epicureans Villa that's
fine you've got a weird body you know
compared to the rest of us and be sort
of like and if people like enjoyed
eating food that well I mean most people
like seafood no spicy for me yeah yeah
okay nobody's spicy for like hot food
yeah yeah but it helped me but it also
creates for a lot of people a release of
endorphins - yeah yeah so that works
yeah but being going back to the
masochism thing being taking pleasure
being humiliated there I think they
would they would find that problematic
you know let's say you know I've never
been asked that before that's a good
question no no it's good yeah
so um how are we doing on time oh I need
to track a little bit about what happens
after Epicurus shuffles off this mortal
coil I will mention to Epicurus and the
Epicureans hard materialists there's no
soul or if there is it's just a bunch of
atoms put together in certain ways so
once you're dead you're dead and you
might say well why did he have a will
then you know why did he care he wanted
to make sure that his legacy would would
survive and the way of life that he was
teaching would continue to be taught and
that that's what's in as well the other
thing that I'll mention about the
Epicureans as well as they saw their
atom estar taking this idea from
Democritus everything that exists is
just combinations of atoms and they said
it's falling in a void that's a little
bit different than our understanding of
atomic theory but he said every once in
a while an atom like goes a weird way he
calls us the swerve there's actually a
book out there called the swerve that
was published in the last 15 years or so
and it's talking about
epicureanism and it's kind of similar to
you know he uses this to try to say
though that's why we have free will but
it's free will on a very very low level
it's hard to explain from an epicurean
perspective with the texts that we have
how you know more robust conceptions of
free will as intentional behavior would
really take place but when you see
people saying things like well
everything on this macro level is
determined but at the quantum level
things aren't that's very similar to
what Epicurus was was proposing when
people try to derive pretty well from
that so he taught this this
comprehensive doctrine and he had
buddies who were sort of helping him out
with it metrodorus was was one of them
Epicurus is the head of the school but
he had he had three other people who
were sort of lieutenants I guess he
could say or you know exo's or however
we want to call it so one of them is
metrodorus metrodorus he was from lamps
axis and along with his
his brother tamakwa tees he joins the
the school there his brother falls out
with with Epicurus and was one of the
detractors he says some bad stuff about
him and metrodorus became like one of
Epicurus his most successful
popularizers he was tireless in that but
then he unfortunately he dies kind of
young compared to Epicurus he's he's 53
and Epicurus would have made him his
successor instead he makes her Markus
his successor we don't have any of his
writings we don't have any metrodorus
his writings unfortunately either and
then there was a third guy who was Paula
Paula lanius he was a mathematician but
it kind of weird one because he
supposedly wrote a book about geometry
saying you know geometry doesn't have
any proper foundation or stuff like
that's like he's you there's a book of
problems that that he wrote but he was
an epicurean and then there were a
number of other people who were in that
group one who I thought was kind of
interesting I wanted to bring up is this
guy Cole Oh tastes
he was he's known as a satirist and he
wrote a book which again we don't have
that it's in the book is called that
it's impossible to live to even little
live according to the doctrines of the
other philosophers so the idea is you
know there's different like options out
there you could be a plaintiff you could
be an Aristotelian you could be a stoic
you could be a skeptic you could be you
know a different kind of hedonist you
could be a cynic or you can be an
epicurean none of these other options
are any good that must have been one
hell of a book I wish we we had it
because it would be interesting to see
and so that this whole group is is
around
he dies and they're having kids and
they're passing on this thing and they
you know they in his lifetime the
instituted thing that epicurean still do
today which is on the 20th of each month
they celebrate Epicurus and
interestingly in antiquity they they
wound up so in one respect they're very
radical you know they're doing all sorts
of things that don't really fit into the
rest of society they're hedonists they
they withdraw from politics as much as
possible they've got their own thing
that they're doing and on the other hand
they're very conservative in that they
they don't really deviate from his his
teachings they don't add an awful lot
more to it as far as we can tell until
till you know later on and again
unfortunately we don't have too much of
what they wrote we do nowadays have a
good bit by this guy Phil add Amos who
was a later epicurean philosopher I
mentioned Herculaneum right Herculaneum
is this place where Phil Adiemus lived
and you know we've we've got a library
from Herculaneum of these these Scrolls
and they're big and they're all kind of
messed up
and so when they first discovered them
about - I think about yeah probably two
centuries ago they they tried to unroll
them and it just like fell apart and so
they're like well but I'll leave these
along and in more recent times they've
developed other ways of you know you
either unrolling the scroll or not
unrolling it and imaging it so it's a
long process the first thing they did is
like you wet them down and you unroll
them very very very slowly like almost a
glacial rate and then you you photograph
what you've got and then people would
you know write out that stuff and so
some of that's been translated so we
have some of Philip Amos writings the
other thing that they're doing now is
they're taking the scrolls themselves
and do
I think x-rays of them and then using AI
programs to reconstruct what's what's on
the scroll so we may in fact wind up
with some other lost works by Epicurus
or not yeah may all be stuff by it just
fill Adiemus but it's kind of nice
in ancient times the Epicureans they got
kind of a bad rap
a lot of other schools of philosophy and
people who don't necessarily belong to a
school themselves but our eclectic the
one school that they're usually unfair
to is the Epicureans and it could be in
part because the Epicureans were very
popular and had a lot of followers it
was also a when it comes to the Roman
stuff there was this perception that we
don't really want these these hedonists
running the show caesar was reputed to
be a a epicurean and you know we well he
was wonderful he was their guy right
well they killed him yeah in some
respects he was that he was quite
popular in other respects he was he was
viewed as kind of a degenerate and
several different accounts usually the
arguments that are made against the
Epicureans are pretty unfair you know
but it's it's good in a way that they
have them because we know more about the
Epicureans from these authors like
Cicero or Plutarch
or locked-on seus who are who are
criticizing them we have these fragments
about well they say Epicurus taught this
and this and this we don't have it in
any other text so it's kind of nice to
have that and Epicureanism more or less
disappears from the scene as
Christianity you know becomes more and
more important in the Roman Empire and
other forms of pagan worship and
philosophy become more important
stoicism had always been a major
opponent
as Neoplatonism comes on the scene the
neoplatonist they hate the Epicureans
too so it's not just a sort of like you
know decline and fall of Rome Gibbon
sort of sort of thing and they they
disappear as a school they're
resuscitated in the Renaissance and
interestingly enough it's a Catholic
priest who plays a big role in that
Pierre Gassendi who you probably
associate with gases right because he
was also a scientist he wrote some some
works arguing for Epicureanism and not
just as a moral philosophy was a natural
philosophy he's arguing for the atomists
point of view and you know it starts to
take off in the 1600 and 1700 and by you
know by a certain point you can say that
at least among the educated classes
there was a revived epicureanism but not
everybody agreed on what what it meant
precisely to be an epicurean some of
them it was you know sort of like just
associated with the hedonism in general
which they called libertinism
stoicism also made a revival around the
same time - and so they are often sort
of opposed to each other and I guess the
only other thing to say about about the
the revival is so in the last twenty
years or so and I think largely because
of the internet and it's its ability to
connect people and provide tax and you
know resources to people there have been
a number of philosophical revivals of
what we call philosophies away weight
philosophy as a way of life and it's not
a radically new thing ancient
philosophies were all philosophies
blessing as a way of life medieval
philosophy was that a lot of modern
philosophy like Rene Descartes is that
there's cartesianism as a philosophy as
a way of life existentialism
was very much about that and then you
know there's some literature about that
the person who coined the term is this
pure dull who is late twentieth century
but none of them knew the internet and
the Internet has made it possible for
people to connect together and for
people to self-publish to in ways that
don't have the appropriate in the past
think back thirty years if you hit a
book and you told somebody that you
published that book yourself and it
wasn't from a regular publisher they'd
be like oh oh yeah sure and you're like
here take a copy there yeah they'd throw
it right in the trash right now it is
that that's gone
so among philosophies is a way of life
stoicism is bigger that that's had a
massive revival in the last fifteen
years but the Epicureans are like second
when it comes to ancient philosophies
that have been resuscitated as a matter
of fact one of the the big people in
that movement lives just you know south
of here and the Chicago suburbs he's got
a book cultivating the epicurean garden
recently another book how to how to how
to be an epicurean came out which is you
know it's okay it's pretty good in some
respects and these are books that are
aimed at people who want to try to live
out that way of life now so there there
is a current day revival of that the
Quirinus I'm going on that's very
different than what we think of as you
know epicureanism and food and drink and
all that and it's kind of a cool thing
to see we're now in a time where
philosophy in general I thought I'd say
is kind of on the rise it's a exciting
time yeah
aren't we need Epicureans say there's no
pathway I mean you just you're you're
done there's no evident how yeah and all
of that I don't know what what did they
did they say there's a God no God
well the Epicureans thought there were
gods and the gods were blessed they
lived a wonderful life they were
immortal and the reason they were
blessed it is because they don't care
anything about what a stupid human
beings are doing they don't pay any
attention to what's going on down well
they I sort of I mean you you couldn't
be Zeus in the way that we typically
think of him and be blessed in the way
the Epicureans are saying because the
Zeus that we know is always getting
himself in trouble with his wife by
screwing around on her and then making
kids that then he had to like worry
about a judicata conflicts between the
gods you know it's a full-time job being
a Zeus these guides they were the the
Greek gods but think about the Greek
gods with all the negative aspects
stripped away and they have no they have
nothing to do you know and the universe
just goes on perfectly well without them
anyway so what what's the point of them
Epicurious exactly we'd have to think
about them at all you know they're just
sort of models for us they don't get
angry they don't get jealous no it's
going so going back to the to the
Catholic thing so there's you know there
were we often think as if like
Christianity and Catholicism was this
monolithic you know way of life you know
that we call the church there in any
given time if we dig into the literature
there was so much crazy stuff going on
just just the every day to day stuff
like ants um who is you know very
saintly guy become becomes a bishop and
then he has to write all these letters
so it's a monastery saying you guys are
screwed up in this way and don't let
that priest go to town because when he
does he gets drunk and causes a scandal
so there's always like all this this
stuff my god
and then there was actually quite a lot
of intellectual freedom in in some
places you know and you sandy took full
advantage of that and and usually when
they're when they're doing that sort of
thing
they've got some way of finagling it the
same thing those were the Stoics too
because the Stoics were were hard
materialists as well but there were you
know Christians taking up the Stoics and
so you you do it you do kind of a
synthesis right but you know the gas nd
was very attracted to this natural
theory of atoms and not too many other
people were working with it so yeah hey
you know there were some other people
Thomas Jefferson said he was in
Epicurean it's kind of debatable exactly
how it was kind of a he's kind of an
eclectic figure himself and a bit of an
outlier but he you know he kind of fits
into that yeah Diderot another another
example denis diderot jeremy bentham
he's you know that there we have
utilitarianism there's a much greater
focus on the community but he saw what
he was doing is within the grand
tradition coming from Epicurus turning
everything into considerations of
pleasures and pains so you know they
think the they've always been a minority
and they've never been you know all the
hedonist surround you can always find
some of those crude people who just want
to get drunk all the time
and enjoy themselves you know back in
the day we look guys you party right
somebody comes up to you at the parking
lot says hey you want a party probably
not an epicurean fine oh there's there's
probably always going to be something
like epicureanism around maybe under
different labels and the people who are
practice practicing it now just like the
people who are practicing it back in the
day and the people who were trying to
use it in say the 17th century they
thought of it as a coherent way of
living that would not just answer
certain questions but like guide you
through having
a happy life with other people too so
yeah so that's that's probably enough
from you know the presentation what
other questions are ideas does it
provoke for you
this guy Epicurus and this progeny so
there's that neutral state you know yeah
especially insofar as when you ask
people so one central practice in in Zen
Buddhism Zen comes with the Chinese word
Shan means meditation right so
meditation has to be absolutely central
in it and you say well what the hell are
you doing when you're meditating you're
just sitting there doing doing nothing
and now they're not doing it just like
obtain pleasure or something like that
they're aiming at enlightenment but you
know there's there's an awful lot of
just like not getting yourself involved
and what's happening over there or you
know another thing too is not like
trying to like be the best meditator
because that's that's work so I think a
lot of people when they meditate and you
know some of you do do it and can tell
me I think a lot of people when they
meditate they actually do it because
they they enjoy taking that time out of
the day not having to screw around with
any of the other BS that were stuck
doing yeah yeah I had an acquaintance
was a yogi for a while and I asked him
well what is it like when you meditate
because when I I don't I'm not a good
meditator I don't actually enjoy it very
much because my mind is a little bit too
too active even overnight when I try to
use like techniques and aids and stuff
like that I've never really been
successful but he was a very calm guy
and I saw so what's it like when you
meditate you know it's an ocean of bliss
you know are you serious you know I was
like in my 20s at the time and and I was
tempted to you know sort of call BS on
that
no no I'm I'm really serious about
that's that's what it's like but then
again I've been doing that for 15 years
yeah I mean for the Epicureans there
were techniques that they would use
mental techniques to try to have a more
pleasant life like you would take a
certain time out of the day and you
would think about previous pleasures
that you'd enjoyed and just you know
don't try to force it but try to you
know get some more enjoyment out of that
or you'd analyze your fears so that you
can you can dispel them it's good things
to do these these are not unique to the
Epicureans but I can tell you one thing
that's sort of a contrast for Stoics one
really central practice is what they
call primitive Tatsuo malorum these days
the Stoics didn't actually call it back
then but it's sort of caught on it means
like thinking about bad things before
they happen not to worry about them but
so that you're inoculated against them
you you you bring up in your mind the
bad thing that you're worried about
happening and then you can see that it's
actually a not that bad that you have
resources to deal with it that you've
made some you know wrong assumptions
about it and then when you actually do
face that thing you often find odds
actually I could deal with this this is
not that bad I may not even have any
negative reaction to it
Epicureans don't do that because they're
like why the hell would you want to
think about something painful before it
happens there's enough pain already in
life just think about pleasant things so
that's one over there there there's a
big contrast between the two of them
what would they feel like going out of
nature and experiencing nature would be
yeah a bunch of them sure oh yeah yeah
it'll become like a new maybe a neutral
kind of pleasure you just watch the
waves come in I mean it could be it
could be both it's interesting I taught
a classroom Milwaukee Institute of Art
and Design last semester
on philosophies as waves of life and
Epicureanism was one of the ones that we
did and I had that is one of the Pratt
I'd suggest to them like a bunch of
practices try this and then I gave them
like worksheets because you like keep
track of what the experience is like for
you and then we compare notes later and
that's one that we tried going and you
know there's other ways to do it with
the Epicurean thing you're really
focusing on are you getting pleasure
from it or not and so they had to
analyze the pleasures at the hand and
some of it was just like so mine is
right on the river so you can you can go
out and set many of the students at my
head still live in the area too
you just go right out and sit and watch
the waves of the river or you could just
go down the lakefront and so some of
them did that and they talked about sort
of you know that experience of you're
not you're not focusing on anything
water is good for that right you're not
focused on any particular thing they're
getting pleasure from it's just sort of
an overall sensation but when the wind
blows and it's nice out because the at
that point in the semester was like
early October you know and you've got
the nice smells which isn't always the
case in the downtown it's coming from
the south side
then maybe it's it's not that good but
but when it's coming from other places
then you get these nice smells and all
that those would be active pleasures
right I mean think about a smell when
you smell something you can only smell
it for a very short amount of time right
that's why we can get used to terrible
smells
fortunately they some of them really
stick with you more of them than others
but the good stuff we smell it and then
it dissipates
that's one reason who the total sino
that's one reason I think why some
people put on too much perfume or
cologne because they spray it out and
they're like I like the way this smells
and then they can't smell it on
themselves even though other people can
smell it on them like ten minutes later
they're like I need another spritz you
know and then you get in the elevator
with them you're like whoa what is that
and they're like what do you mean you
know
good our new precarious today reconcile
mental illness Oh
for example mental illness where you're
hallucinating
yeah reality it's not what it really is
yeah you know or or you could say in the
case of that sort of thing you can also
have virtual reality and you could have
like well I suppose if it's drugs or
something FB hallucinations - alright if
it's Pleasance it's still real the
pleasure is real
most people with mental illnesses it's
not a lot of pleasures more you know
pains and anxieties and troubles that
they're they're having and you know the
Epicureans they they it's interesting
they in ancient times not just the
Epicureans but sort of across the board
including the medical profession they
they thought of a lot of things that we
nowadays wouldn't call mental illnesses
they saw they saw sort of continuum
between moral vices and mental illnesses
so then one of the nexuses was was
emotion right so losing your temper too
too much nowadays we send people to
anger management and maybe they do
cognitive behavior techniques or
something like that or they give you you
know they give you some pills to change
your brain chemistry but the you know
the Epicureans actually they talked
quite a bit about anger fill the Dana
sense the whole text on it Stoics the
the there was a Chilean is the plateless
they all they all develop very robust
ways of helping individuals change their
their habits their assumptions their
reactions to things and they used that
that that notion of illness to be out of
control with respect to anger was
morally vicious but it was also mentally
there was a mental illness and and they
saw a mind-body connection to you know
Galen is a really an interest
guy in that respect you know we don't
buy into much of his like humor theory
right nobody uses that in medicine
anymore I thank God boy when it comes to
the cognitive side of it he was it was
pretty on point for quite a few things
and you know I guess one of the other
things we think about what if there was
somebody who's mentally ill in in such a
way that they would never be able to not
let's take anxiety they would never
because of their brain chemistry they
would never be living a life in which
they were free of fear right there
weren't anything like pills to give at
the time like xanax or anything like
that which is kind of a trade-off anyway
you know people get over medicated it
doesn't it's not a pleasant life but
what would that be like if they were in
the Epicurean community it probably
would would suck for them but you know
they could still do some epicurean
things they could try to minimize the
amount of fear that they're feeling or
not have not feel the fear then
immediately react and do something
that's gonna lead to more pain later
like withdraw from relationships or
things like that and so again we don't
we don't really know much about this but
we can presume that something like that
probably came up quite a bit in
Epicurean communities and then hopefully
they would they would try to work with
the person you know and they were
probably kind of a pain in the rear for
other people to deal with - yeah you
know if you get somebody who's got
mental illness and your family it's
gonna generate a lot of trouble and pain
for you but you know there's there's
ways to manage it's with less at least
but they would be precluded from living
the good life you know
oh well that's that's they they thought
that was the case a lot of the time
that's in fact where the virtue of
courage or fortitude comes in you take
on stuff that sucks right now and is
painful or disturbing and it'll pay off
in pleasure later right so like good
thinking about going to the gym yeah so
you say you go to the gym and when
you're first going boy doesn't suck
you know the workout hurts you're you're
looking around and everybody else on the
gym and you're like they're able to do
these weights why can't I just see if
you feel embarrassed and you know you're
probably upset with yourself for having
let yourself get out of shape and all
that sort of stuff and you know it's
funny because because you know I'm in
the process of trying to get back in
shape
we've we've been members of the
Wisconsin Athletic Club now for about
two years and you know I go regularly
and then things happen get sick or it
could get too much work and then then
I'm not doing it regularly but you know
I've done it long enough now that some
some stuff sticks with me and so you
know my wife will ask did you have a
good workout and my answer is it was a
workout
any of them are good workouts yet where
I like enjoying you know doing the
exercises but it doesn't suck right
whereas in the past that really did and
you know maybe five years from now I'll
actually enjoy going to the gym I like
going in the sauna afterwards like not
working
you know and I certainly do like be you
know not being winded as I go up the
stairs or not having any problem picking
up boxes or things like that that I
would have had problems with two years
ago so there's there's pleasure that
comes from that but you have to put up
the stuff that you don't like in order
to get that right and then study is like
that too
there's a lot of things that we study
that it's not enjoyable but it's gonna
pay off for us later or are they the
example about working right you go to go
to your job and you got to put up with
your boss and they're you listen to
their stupid stories and
you know fill out the forms that they
want you to fill out that nobody will
ever read and this customer you know
complains about this and then your your
reward is you get to go home and look in
your direct deposit because now
everybody uses that and see the money
yeah you know do the things you want to
do right so there's plenty of cases
where you incur something painful in
order to you need to now have more pain
later on or to enjoy some some sort of
pleasure and the you know the working
out is a good example of I'm working out
right now
as I approach 50 because I don't want to
be 60 and overweight and have I already
have some joint pain I'd like to have
less of it and I'd like to feel more
like I'm up to whatever challenges life
puts in front of me I don't really care
about my appearance that much that I you
know I left a decade ago I'm never gonna
try to be ripped or anything but I want
I want to not have pains later on like
not being able to do something with my
kids that they'd like to do because I
out of shape so you'll have a better
appreciation I mean oh yeah that's the
posters that you'll have later yeah
exactly
ya know how bad it can be you know at
work or whatever yeah the pleasures
Kankan like they're not all like
discrete units right they can they can
sort of play off of each other so you
know ideally if it's possible to
harmonize pleasures that's what you do
is an epicurean so that you have a even
more pleasant life
yeah any other questions or I think it's
a little bit hard to be an epicurean
today just because we live really long
live oh and we restored paint our bodies
break down so we get more of that
physical immediate pain just by and by
just by nature so that's really hard
yeah there's no way out of that well no
I think that's a really good point I
mean we do with what we know about the
body now and about nutrition and health
and stuff like that if we if we want to
and we're not screwed by the genetic
lottery we we can we can reduce a lot of
the problems that people had in old age
but people do live way longer and so
there's this this Twilight where it
could be quite painful or upsetting and
we can also add like your friends all
died on you and you know I think about
my grandma who died when she was 93 she
she didn't realize that's pretty angry
she was causing to my aunt her daughter
where like every meal she'd say why
can't I just die everybody else is gone
we'd be like where everybody else you
know and yeah exactly
yeah so that that is an issue I mean you
wouldn't you wouldn't be having the the
best epicurean life you could say but I
can still help you manage the life that
you've got so that it's less painful you
know and then maybe that's the best you
can you can have yeah and then and then
do what just like functional for that
point in life yeah there's a guy he gave
a talk at Stone yeah there's this guy
who gave a talk at Stoke out a couple of
years ago a a long big big scholar of
Hellenistic philosophy so he's done a
lot of work in Epicureans and skeptics
and stoic
and I forget exactly how he portioned it
out but he was like well in this part of
the day I'm a stoic this part of the day
I'm just captain this part of the day I
haven't have to carry it maybe that's
the way to do it well thanks very much
for your question
[Music]
you